so full disclosure we're gonna Photoshop
some cleavage on you in the thumb
because you haven't why not
oh the internet will go crazy girl you
know you hang out with darren meyer and
my lowly innopolis no one thinks of you
as a good conservative girl alright we
are back and already not gay jared has
screwed up send your complaints to at
not gay Jared I fulfilled my legal
obligations but follow him and draw your
own conclusions particularly Saturday
the 14th I would recommend you check out
the pictures so next guest I'm very
excited to have on we've discussed
certain topics when we've been in Google
Hangouts with Miley innopolis and I've
worked with the rebel TV up there in
Canada of course where I was raised so
you can go to the rebel dot media I
think or follow her on Twitter Lauren
underscore southern on the Twitter I
have messed this up brutal it's because
not gay Jared screwed me up Lauren thank
you for coming on the show thank you for
having me Steven and I apologize for
being what am I an hour late I am the
worst guest actually it was my fault
because I visited my family in there in
central time so when I put it on our I
calendar so honestly it was just a
screw-up all around what we generally do
in these instances is we just blame not
gay Jared oh yeah
so he'll be he'll be fired you okay
we're good we're good I'm you know I
just it's par for the course
I was I was prepared for this going in
2016 it's par for the course so good so
Lauren okay so you work with the rebel
media right there was Sun news and it's
up and now when I was there I've talked
about this with Gavin and Ezra there
were no Conservatives I mean I was
raised in Quebec I understand you're out
in Western Canada but in Quebec we had
liberals and liberal separatists so
before we get into I know you've talked
a lot about gender politics and we'll
get into immigration
how would you sort of identify yourself
do you think you're more libertarian I
mean in Canada terms have different
meanings yeah for Canada they would
consider me an extremist on the right
still yes I'm a libertarian but I would
consider myself a little more
conservative
on my own level okay um but I wouldn't
want to force on people that is uh you
they say that the Republicans are always
twenty years behind the Democrats here
it's like our Conservatives are five
years behind the Liberals right
yeah yes even Harper's even opera was
the first guy I voted for though and I
remember none of my friends in Quebec I
mean he might have gotten like 1% of the
vote and I have no idea no one I knew
outside of my direct family by their
votes for him I miss him right now to be
honest Trudeau is just hilarious just
ridiculous with every policies put in
place well he's the social justice
warrior prime minister he is the total
identity politics metrosexual
androgynous sort of [ __ ] looking just
a really really weird uncomfortably
politically correct dude and like him or
hate him was Stephen Harper the one
thing and there was a lot of things I
didn't like but there are a lot of
things that I did like you kind of knew
where he was going with things he didn't
really pull a lot of bait and switch do
even most liberal Canadians recognize
that do you feel about what Stephen
Harper even if they didn't like his
policies um no they just kind of had the
party line that they would repeat why
they hate him oh he passed bill c-51 Oh
Harper bought a few jets a few years ago
that cost for this amount of money Oh
Stephen Harper is a war monger and even
though we barely got involved in any
wars no I is very likely going to waste
far more money than Stephen Harper did
on his Jets that he bought brand Trudeau
signed bill c-51 the information bill
where they're similar to your Patriot
Act in Canada yeah that's that's a most
of the stuff that they have on Harper
they're going to have on Trudeau
eventually Wow that doesn't matter
that's not relevant to intellectual
political discussion what can you slap
on a bumper sticker hey make Canada
great again
so it's 2015 right yeah you uh you
you've discussed a lot about gender
politics and obviously you went to the
feminist [ __ ] walk as they call it and
asked some some great questions that's
how I became introduced to you but
you've been talking now how you have
something going up you're talking
about immigration a lot which I'm
curious to sort of hear your thoughts
because in Canada it's not the same
hot-button issue as it is in the United
States generally because you don't have
a massive demand of people just running
over the border trying to get in and my
my dad was a legal immigrant to Canada
when he married my mom and we lived
there and my mom is now illegal she's
legal status in the United States so
she's been going through the process
really her whole life so we've always
been abreast of it but we were always
sort of surprised as to how ignorant
Canadians were on that issue and now you
were kind of telling me all ferrets it's
devolving a little bit um I don't want
to put words in your mouth you were
talking sort of like is it the
multicultural segregation what's going
on don't really talk much about
immigration you're right and I think
it's because we get a lot of very
peaceful immigrants we don't know what
it's like to have like Germany where
they're having tons and tons of people
come over their border that aren't
necessarily peaceful right and also they
kind of screen them to make sure that
they're gonna get a job when they're
over here so we have a nice kind of an
immigration however what we're seeing
now and I'm gonna have a video come out
maybe today I'm not sure when this is
going up but today tomorrow and it's
gonna make a lot of people mad just
because I do discuss how
multiculturalism in Canada although we
do have a lot of peaceful groups coming
here it's completely segregated the kind
they stay the kind of multiculturalism
they sell to us at the government where
everyone's holding hands around the
globe from their different cultures and
the force diversity shoots for
university campuses that I have been in
and dragged into campus that's not the
reality of it we've got areas that are
70 percent 80 percent just one group
immigrants from one area and not only
that day this has caused a little bit of
an issue over signage because I can't go
into areas and shop in certain areas
because none of the signs are in English
right and you walk through entire
streets without seeing English or being
able to speak your language also
depending on the area a little bit more
rape yeah yeah that's something to the
people little rapey the Islamic cultures
it's kind of a trademark all the great
smoth have their calling card as is rape
so it's um you know you see that with
Sweden Sweden's become the rape
capital of Western Europe and in German
havoc like kind of area in Canada yes
well we did in Montreal yeah in montreal
montreal Westmount was where most of the
jewish population was there were a lot
of Lebanese so some of them were
Lebanese Catholic but I mean I had a lot
of Muslims at school I've talked about
this at Centennial where I watched a few
of them laugh at 9/11 and every single
Muslim I knew at Centennial Regional
High School in Greenfield Park every
single one hated Jews no exception hey
did Jews Lauren it wasn't like kind of
maybe a hated them and I remember being
so surprised when I asked him after 9/11
about Osama bin Laden I said ok walk me
through this Osama bin Laden according
to your religion you believe in Hell
right yes we believe now okay so he's
going to hell none of them would say no
none of them would say no as a matter of
fact if you said yes outright and if you
were like well it always depends and you
weigh your good deeds and your bad deeds
so where I grew up there was a lot of
that and and that was a big part of what
shaped my view I actually read the Quran
because it was handed to me at the
Islamic Club at Champlain College and I
thought like this is this these have to
be typos this is incredible um so I
guess I don't know what it's like an in
Western Canada but when you say
segregation so how does that shape up is
it like New York where it's organic and
she's like okay the Greeks are here and
maybe you have like this area that's
Jewish or literally just they don't even
speak the language they don't assimilate
at all yeah it's it's obvious natural I
think that a lot of people they aren't
encouraged to even become a Canadian or
know what the Canadian identity is when
they come here so they'll just go to
kind of the sex or it's like oh this
place already speaks my language why
would I bother to learn this whole new
language when quite frankly I never have
to write I can just go to this one area
and I remember in the video you'll see
it there's this one school that was
literally 100% South Asian every child
there was South Asian and they were all
speaking the same language and it wasn't
english it was just like you can grow up
there too and not never speak the
language there are schools there's a
creative as well yeah
well it's weird in Quebec with a warped
view because of the language laws
so it's the one area in order to try and
promote multiculturalism of a conquered
people the French people who should have
been spanked and no sorry [ __ ] you're
speaking English we let them have their
little area and then they try to exclude
exclude English people and the signage
that's what I was thinking you were
talking about you know in Quebec French
writing has to be exactly 2.5 times the
size of English writing on any sign or
menu and Stephens diner at least when I
lived there I don't know if they still
the language police Stephens diner
apostrophe s shut down because it's
English writing you can't have an
English name yeah to the point where
they were even thinking of changing the
name of like Burger King and all of
those things Montreal I don't think it
went through so that's what I was
thinking you were talking about are we
talking about this with Gavin it's sort
of the reverse where they call it pol n
you know means pure wool and trying to
keep like pure French European blood
well their language laws encouraged a
huge Haitian immigration little known
fact French Canadians some of the racist
people on the planet so so now they find
themselves in a quandary
is that is Montreal not even considered
Canada to the rest of Canada that's what
people have told me well it's true and
it seemed like you haven't screwed it up
nearly as badly as Eastern Canada has so
okay so how do you compare it to like
the United States and in this sort of
project you're working on what would be
a better way to do it the melting pot
you know the United States making sure
they learn the light or or is that just
racist are you a racist you're a racist
people call me one for stating facts
stating that people are segregated I
guess so but in it with the melting pot
that's one thing when people come into
Canada they aren't told like what a
Canadian identity is that we should be
talking to each other we should be
working together instead our current
governments motto is diversity is our
strength and if you get a chance I've
watched the video where Chrystia
Freeland one of our gender balance
cabinet chicks she's one of the new
ministers wait is that an official
position no no I'm just assuming she was
brought on to make this oh okay
and they asked him Justin why do you
have a gender balance cabinet and he
replies it's 2015 yeah well I guess
instead of like qualifications or resume
the year works as well that on the
website for $100 it's amazing but
Christina is one of the ministers in his
cabinet and she went and debated Bill
Maher and Bill Maher is like Christian
you can't just like bring a ton of
people in from a different country that
car from an entirely different culture
especially one like Islamic culture
where a lot of them are going to be
Reaper raphe or radical and Christian is
just like he can just hear she's trigger
and she's like we don't say things like
that in Canada yeah
your bill is just losing his mind
talking to her and that's what you know
and her are like Trudeau's Senate
diversity is our strength speech as well
but when you go and you look at it on
the ground that's a myth being
segregated by race and language and all
these different things that is not our
strength being able to talk and
communicate and maybe share different
cultures under the same language and not
natural segregation rather that might be
a strength but that's not what's
happening in reality right even if you
don't believe the judeo-christian faith
at all like the tower just think of the
Tower of Babel as an Aesop fable like it
should be it should be the perfect
analogy ok now we're all speaking these
different languages and it really
screwed us over yeah it's um it is and I
do think and people like you and Milo
and Gavin and you know I'd be humbled
and honored to include myself I think
there's a movement afoot where you're
never going to have young people
politically turn toward conservatism yet
you know convincing them of tax law when
they don't really pay taxes it's tough
the free stuff is still an easy sell but
the diversity and the political
correctness and this this really you
know cultural Marxism is thrown around
so much but that's what it is in this
case I definitely I mean you've you've
gotten in this more recently you know
I've been doing this for a while now
I've noticed a significant shifting a
changing of the tides where people are
open to hearing
things you have to say and they don't
just call you a racist anymore yeah
definitely well when you say it so many
times that loses its meaning and even
the people who are called racist so many
times like probably yourself myself my
loan it just rolls off our shoulders
Trump doesn't even have to acknowledge
it anymore
and people don't even focus on that
because it's like you can keep calling
him a racist he's not even going to
acknowledge it that word has no meaning
yes we have to go to a break and we will
bring you back because I want to get
into the campus talk and discuss it
Lauren southern rebel dot meet the rebel
dot maybe a lot of risk riders stay
tuned we'll be right back we are back
with the one and only Lauren southern
follow her on Twitter at Lauren
underscore southern Canadian but is is
on top of American politics as well so
you were talking about this we're
talking how there is kind of a shift in
in people speaking out against political
correctness not really accepting the
being called a racist being called a
sexist you mentioned it's different on
campus I still maintain that on campus
the majority of students just want to
get to class and get their degree it's
this small percentage that just make the
loudest noise that may be true but even
the rest of the students because of the
climate that is on campus you don't
really question the narrative especially
not in classes because the professor's
won't accept the narrative being
questioned on campus there are the
militant groups are these s2w groups so
you don't want to get in trouble with
them keep your head down laughs when the
professor makes jokes about Republicans
or conservatives and whatever someone in
the class dares to question that make
sure to laugh at them - yeah you know
it's funny I had a teacher well this
could be her name is Helen Holt her name
was Helen halted Champlain College
Helen Holt at Champlain College took off
all the Christian holidays Jewish
holidays and apparently there were
Buddhist holidays because she was like
some tantric Buddhist or whatever the
hell this looks like a female drew Carey
do you even idea the kind of psychopath
she was she would read books correct
them with a red pen and mail it back to
the authors and it was like Greek myth
of Mythology with a humanities course
was the only one left and she told me
first yes who's here is a consider
themselves a Christian and I raised my
hand and she said you're probably not
gonna pass my class because you can't
open your mind enough to like what we're
learning about
about hercules like this is not and I
did fail our class and then I had
another teacher who was very far left
and we connected because we both did
Juno and he actually he's the only
teacher who ever gave me a hundred
percent on two papers that I wrote and
so I there is hope there I do think
there's some decent people but yeah
there are a lot of Helen Holtz in the
world and I remember just being like I
just can't believe this is allowed and
it goes unfettered but I don't think
most of those students would have been
far left
like you said they just you think they
just sort of accept the culture by
default you know what thinking back when
you get to the real crazies like your
professor I had a real crazy professor
in my first year and I don't think the
students like too much because of that
okay maybe I think it's still the
heads-down thing but I did hear that I
was kicked out of this class in my first
year this professor he taught us to
spell everything wrong because he was
part of the some Kohner progressive
English you can spell it however you
want kind of group and this was an
academic writing course if you ever get
the chance look up the poet Bill Bissett
I don't wanna I don't wanna well you
Canadian spell everything wrong anyway
you put a you or it doesn't belong the
color exam had a poem by this bill
Bissett guy and it's a poem about how
George Bush should be put in prison for
war crimes and his entire everyone that
was on his campaign staff everyone that
worked for him should be killed except
killed was like spelt ke e LED and
should was s ult on a second is that is
the logic behind that because I've read
about this before is it that certain
people in impoverished communities or
minorities who don't have access to the
same kind of education may spell things
differently and that's okay so we should
accept all of it is that the logic
behind it because I've read those
theories before you'd have to look at
Bill Bissett website because it's all in
Comic Sans and it's all different colors
and the words are all over the place and
like it's purposely made to be bad it's
post modernist and I think more so than
it is social justice II but everything
we read in this class was social justice
oriented like Israel is bad I
here's how black people suffer Wow LGBTQ
everything we read in that class with
social justice oriented even though it
was an academic long ago was it that was
a year and a half ago well guess what a
year and a half ago wasn't LGBTQ is
LGBTQ certainly wasn't LGBTQ aai as
they're now saying four and that's not
if people think I'm joking with it LGBTQ
you know lesbian gay bisexual
transgender queer or questioning
depending that you ask asexual allies
and intersex and some people want to add
p4 pansexuals would be LGBTQ a AIP and
I'm not so when people think like I'm
not exaggerating when I add like the
silent F and a number five but it's not
that far off take me to prison in New
York for getting that wrong too now with
the pronoun laws or if I'm a landlord in
New York for those listening we've
talked about it we've written about this
extensively on the site in New York if
you're a landlord and you make you know
you have a communal restroom sometimes
kind of like a hotel you rooms will have
the restrooms but sometimes there's a
main restroom and you make a man who
claims to be a woman use the man's
restroom you can be fined and really to
the point that your business isn't is in
peril if I'm a landlord in New York I go
men's room I deal with the consequences
where are you gonna have their admirer
on after you who is a more libertarian
transsexual who disagrees with a lot of
this so there are those people I get a
lot of emails from people like that who
are gay who are you know alternative and
and they don't they feel I think what's
happened you tell me if I'm wrong here I
think with the same-sex marriage thing
now that that's done leftists have lost
a big tool and now more people are
looking at their other ideas and
realizing there's nothing there for them
so they just keep getting new cards I
all you had to do was watch the
Democratic stage to see all these white
people on the stage trying so hard to
get their victim cards I'm a woman then
I think it was like O'Malley I'm younger
than you guys I'm from a different
generation and Darren and I go out for
drinks all the time actually she lives
right near me and ya know Darren hates
that nonsense
but yeah and I know we'll disagree but
I'm willing to have anyone on who can
have a sensible discussion okay so the
immigration issue will be looking
that and we're seeing that here in the
United States I think that's just an
issue where it's one of those issues
where I think it shows you that um the
Democratic Party and I don't know if
it's the same in Canada it is no longer
really for the working class it's for
the non working class and the elites you
know though I'm smoking my mission pipe
with my my glove and the people who are
on welfare or people who are looking to
remain permanently unemployed because
even Democrats and we have to go hydros
have to go to break
longtime Democrats who work have a
problem with immigration illegal
immigration right it's not a winning
issue with those people because they
don't want their jobs being taken but it
seems the Democratic Party has abandoned
them I wonder if it's the same thing in
Canada
okay last real quick and I will go to
the web extended version if you can fit
it in twenty seconds to the left that
people are like Oh bringing in tons of
immigrants that's beautiful that's
excellent we're spending eighty billion
dollars hosting them in 5-star hotels
no biggie yeah well five okay well I'm
gonna fact-check you on that when we go
to the web expecting louder with greater
calm or rebel dot media for the web
extended version Lauren southern stay
tuned more louder with crowd after this
subscribe by clicking my face or the
button above or you oh it's you why
don't you have a girlfriend yet